president Trump's lawyer telling
Democrats the White House will not
participate in Monday's impeachment
hearing this comes as House Speaker
Nancy Pelosi is raising questions about
the Democrats motives for investigating
president Trump take a look at this
damage that this administration has done
to America America's a great country we
can sustain two terms I don't know
civilization as we know it today is at
stake in the next election and one of
president Trump's biggest critics
congressman Al Green not ruling out
impeaching the president multiple times
a president can be impeached more than
once
we can still investigate other issues
and when the president has committed
additional offenses and my suspicion is
that he will we can take those before
the Senate there is no limit on the
number of times the Senate can vote to
convict or not a president no limit to
the number of times a house can vote to
impeach or not a president does that
mean this is never-ending you're looking
at me anytime we have to cover this oh I
am I mean the White House won't
participate we should do the same
because now what what what he's just
said is that the Dems in the media look
at impeachment as like an unlimited game
of corn oil or beanbag it's a as long as
they can keep throwing it there's no
reason to stop because there no concern
no consequences to this action why stop
there at the blackjack table playing
with our money so there has to be
consequences meaning that we have to
look and see when this is all over and
done with and it will be we have to look
at what are the consequences what are
the abuses of power that they're
participating in right now we got to
figure out how to remove senators and
congressmen for that very is the threat
to civilization is what they're doing
right now in it and the best part about
this is today massive job numbers record
low unemployment the best economy in my
lifetime and I'm like 35 good news is
for the Dems and good news for the media
is kryptonite to them you look at CNN
how dreadful it is for them to report
the good news it's
eating them alive so they cling to
impeachment like a long-lost lover
because it's the only thing that have at
they have that keeps them afloat so
Jessie what I guess greens point was if
you get new information then you can act
on it green predicted trump was going to
commit more impeachment and we know he
said the same thing last year he said we
have to impeach him because we know we
can't beat them and that's what this is
one they hate him because they can't
beat him he's not a threat to
civilization I mean look at this suit
you're wearing $40 on the hike here that
was just the appetizer
listen Trump is not a threat to
civilization he's a threat to the
Democrats power and that's what this is
about
by pumping Trump up to make him look
like he's the biggest and the baddest
man out there he does feel like he's the
biggest and baddest man it's almost
helping him and it's helping his
supporters and they get it wrong every
time they're like bad weather men that
say there's going to be a cat 5
hurricane month after month after month
and then every time it's downgraded to
beautiful and sunny and that's why we
don't trust these people anymore because
they're constantly wrong now think about
what they've done in terms of abuse of
power and you just mentioned that
they've now accessed rudy giuliani's
phone records after they raided the last
lawyer Trump's had office and they
wiretapped his presidential campaign
okay so if you think about abuse of
power that's where the abuse of power is
and there's this play a little game
right now imagine if Lanny Davis
crooked Hillary's lawyer's office had
been raided his phone records have been
seized his phone calls were tapped that
would have been bananas but this is just
like any other day let me so like if if
Lanny Davis had was spending time in
Ukraine right now Republicans would be
apoplectic like someone not going to
Prague to hatch a witch oh because I see
Giuliani is in the Ukraine right now
Martha let's go back to Nancy Pelosi
because my friends here say hey you know
she's making this out to be civilization
is at stake with Trump
this is ridiculous but I know it's Nancy
Pelosi's never lost a vote and next week
you're gonna be on the camera a lot
because it looks like she's gonna call
for an impeachment vote yeah I find the
pacing very interesting here everybody
can't wait to get this over with at this
point I think the American people and I
know Greg Gutfeld and are included but
you know the definition of civilization
is society culture and a way of life I
think she's working very hard to
convince people and and her verbiage on
this has been escalating over the last
several days it's you know it's Grievous
it's an insult to the Constitution now
the entire civilization is beginning to
crumble because of this and I think that
that is a ramp up not only to her own
Democrat constituency but to these
people that the Washington Post thinks
are undecided and in the middle who you
have to start to lean a lasso and make
sure that they get it because they're
very upset that the reporting isn't
doing a good enough job I just think the
fact that she's speaking in these terms
makes it very clear that she is she's
concerned that it's not strong enough to
get it over the finish line and just one
more thing your point is it has to be
stressed they were asking to
propagandize yes they want to make like
movie trailers but she said you know
what why are journalists shouting into
the void yeah you know you need to work
harder to bring over the undecided so I
don't know in my in my world we try to
tell people what's going on on all sides
of the fence here we don't shout at one
side to try to convince them that the
other side is right who knows but just
to pick up here real quickly do you
think she has the votes or you it's a
question I think the White House thinks
that everybody at this point I think
it's pretty clear they they're just
gonna pass in the house and then they
got to figure out what a thorough you're
gonna take it up in the Senate Emily
only come to you on a legal puzzler
which is you see complaints Jesse
mentioned this about the fact that phone
records were obtained by the Democrats
of phone logs between Giuliani and some
of the Ukrainian Nationals going in but
there's no indication from shift that he
ever subpoenaed the record so the
question is where do these phone records
come from and
was it as Jesse suggested maybe an
overreach on the part of investigators
absolutely and there's a specific point
to that that I want to talk about did
you guys see this morning congressman
congressman Eric swallow he came on
America's newsroom and he said something
to the effect of will don't talk to
indicted felons if you don't want your
call on now that is exactly the elitism
that we are dealing with from the left
it is a luxury for him this privileged
white boy who grew up in Dublin for him
for him to Sonia OH
who was a prosecutor for him to say I've
never talked to an indicted felon well
guess what I have I've talked to a lot
and there's a lot of Americans that have
that felony conviction and that record
and for him to display that hubris which
I'm sure he displayed as a prosecutor
I'm sure justice for him wasn't
collaborative I'm sure it was just
seeking convictions that's what we're
dealing with and that is why the
Democrats don't care us but especially
him as their poster child don't care
about the FISA abuse of power they don't
care if the government is surveilling
its citizens as long as the citizens are
the GOP and they're Republicans on the
hill and he tells the president to grow
up I want him to grow up I want the
Democrats to grow up he tells the
president he says you're wasting
taxpayer dollars on pressuring foreign
powers no you're wasting my tax dollars
all of them you know what it's amazing
about you is that because you're from
Oakland you spit out the word Dublin
like it was the same he's from Dublin
California she's like you think he's
from Dublin